ladies and gentlemen we are here today
to watch another episode of brooklyn
nine nine thank you so much for being
here and thank you to wahoo actually
stick with us on this long ass journey
if you can go ahead and hit that like
button that would be amazeballs
subscribe and click the notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next b99 is up you can catch
these full-length watch alongs over at
our patreon page uh become a super eject
today and uh thanks to the boys at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights of swinging action boys and
girls and everything in between
i'm here i'm here sorry charles power
went out last night and my alarm didn't
go off
sorry i'm late sarge no hot water this
morning but i'm here ready to go will
cause no further distractions
i'm here i'm here i'm here and i'm a
half an hour early peralta you failed
your drug test there were traces of
cocaine and methamphetamines found in
your urine oh what what
that's strange that's not right i hope
this is the actual episode and not just
some opener this is insane i don't do
drugs yeah those tests are unreliable
okay let's not blame tess
someone's trying to sabotage me and who
would want to do that probably someone i
put away it's the only explanation why
you didn't pay your bills and you only
put a quarter gallon of gas in your tank
because you want to spend the rest on
mini-mart beef jerky
i'll talk to one police plaza and
arrange an appeal i'll also put someone
on this uh sabotage theory i got it
jake when i find whoever did this to you
i'm going to rip out their eyeballs and
fill their size i think you might be too
close to this copy that
in the meantime peralta you're suspended
i'm going to need you to hand in your
badging gun all right fine you can have
my badging gun but we're doing it in
your office so i can slam them down on
your desk and yell out the system sticks
actually the procedure is to bring your
gun and badge down to the equipment room
on the second floor
and then receive a claim check through
it or office mail the system
sticks any progress with that extortion
case you and jacob been working on no
i've just been going over his notes look
how cool and illegible this handwriting
is
i wish i could be that free but you know
me ever the calligrapher
well i'm assigning you a new partner
partners
yep oh no yes
gina's dance concert was last night i've
been so preoccupied with peralta's drug
test it totally slipped my mind maybe
gina did it i told her we were there
well i wish you hadn't involved me in
your deception you're gonna blow up my
spot and tell gina the truth if she asks
me then yes i suppose i will have to
blow your spot right up oh no wow you
pissed off a lot of people well that's
what happens when you live out loud rosa
we need to look into the power outage
and hot water do you have proof you pay
your bills are you serious talking about
your finances makes me sweat behind the
knees nice hey speaking of funky smells
oh
i know technically i'm not supposed to
help out but rules are made to be broken
they were made to be followed nothing is
made to be broken uh pinatas
karate boards spaghetti when you have a
small pot rules wrapping paper
the internet says this is the number one
urinalysis lab in all of new york
anyways i'm going to take a walking tour
in here while you guys ask a couple of
questions and also i've been waiting for
20 minutes where have you been
we got coffee
is this heritage there but iceland yes
no no no no
what are you guys talking about yogurt
me too let's keep talking about that
terry's out of breath cool you must not
be in good shape man i want to ask the
captain for his impression of my show
actually i thought it was amazing you
were like a swan who went to juilliard
it was i have already received your
praise i'm clearly fishing in another
pond right now
jeffords and i were unable to attend a
performance
but you were so spot on with your
compliments terry is a practiced liar oh
you think my dancing is a hobby like me
an antique globe collecting
but nobody is ever going to pay me for
it ergo a hobby i get paid in applause
but apparently not yours i know that
maintaining integrity can be difficult
but in the long run
everyone is better for it
oh no
the tragic sound you hear is the
shredding of my spandies gina lynnetti
will never dance again oh man oh so
those threatening phone calls were being
made to tim orsk of timo's limos
this horse guy's name keeps cropping up
in this case because he's the victim
[Laughter]
sure but what do they want from
when you finally change lanes an hour
from now you should go talk to jake's
super see if there was a power outage
what what
did you do
i just broke into your car and then
popped up without warning not cool
excellent timing
it's your fault we have to check up on
your power outages you have three mini
fridges plugged into the same outlet
three mini fridges are cheaper than one
regular one
all right fine you don't want my help
you're not gonna get it dude just let us
take you home see you never
fine
where am i
[Music]
oh jesus what the [ __ ]
oh no cocaine
[Laughter]
auto reveals
you never should have arrested me but i
basically got your cocaine charges
dropped you only had to do 40 hours of
community service right but i wanted to
get them all done at once so for energy
i did way too much cocaine
i lost my job my wife my home the next
client let me this truck he likes me
because i got him off on a strangle at
mangle oh
now i'm just another idiot living in an
ice cream truck so that's why you put
drugs in my urine hey that was my urine
[Laughter]
oh
people are gonna notice if i disappear
shut up peralta oh boy
here's your comp stat report walking is
too close to dancing and there's no more
dancing
plus i'm hoping my leg muscles will
atrophy
i bet you feel real good about calling
her dancing a hobby huh sarcasm the
cowards lie
[Laughter]
pretty good gag huh prostitute taught me
how to make uh i had to grab a few
things at the art supply store
kidnapping is 90 crafting
you're gonna confess on video to framing
me for everything that got me in trouble
and why would i do that because i'm high
on bath salts emotionally unstable and
pointing a gun at you let's make a movie
guess who caught the timo's limo's
purple we listened to those voicemails
again and noticed the sound of parrots
in the background the landscaping in
front of his building was covered with
these same type of rock that was thrown
through the window i can't believe it
you don't think you can break one watch
oh no no
i meant i can't believe you solved the
case well you're wrong on that too
scully and hitchcock
i am a horrible person who has done
horrible things to a truly decent man
which is why i've decided to take my own
life oh no your life's not so bad living
in an ice cream truck never showering
that was my childhood dream i had
everything and friends a wife two
beautiful children out of three total
not a bad ratio
[Laughter]
drugs make me say such silly things
drugs are so silly oh i'm gonna do some
right now poison what
nice nice that's my nose that's where i
put the drugs in
oh so long points man
ugh
i can't move i'm turtling
i'm turtling
dancing is
more than just a hobby for you it's a
profession oh so you're a liar like
terry now no i'm no bunny buying coward
[Laughter]
that's great perform two shows at our
at-risk youth program thank you captain
this is the best eight thousand dollars
you ever spent it's 200
i'm sure you're good for the rest
oh no
we were bonding
talking about our pain and you pull a
stunt like that you were going to kill
me deflect deflect
[Laughter]
i recognize that voice
all right
hello
oh who damn wait how did you find me he
hadn't done anything super annoying to
us for like five hours so he knew
something was wrong
for some reason i have trouble believing
people actually have my back i don't
know why probably my dad abandoning me
maybe something i should work out in
therapy but who has an hour to spare
once every two weeks right
[Laughter]
years since you got off coke and meth
that was the hard one to kick no the
hard one to gig is angel dust which is
why i am locked in for life
sorry for calling you useless i want to
make sure everyone knows you did good
boy please don't oh no he is suddenly be
on everyone's a-list the ones to watch
the golden boys a pair of red hot dicks
don't tell anyone about the amazing work
we did today i never said amazing kind
of just did your job
just take form 891 underscore jay down
to the equipment room and retrieve your
things there i'm sorry but that's
unacceptable
come on captain i need this we
[Laughter]
fine if this will make you happy
i believe these belong to you
i say we march down to city hall out of
my office
that's so fun
i never want them to end
just the views our videos keep dipping
do what they will
get them up people
watch every reaction thrice
have been suspended from a job
no
no you've been reading up before i have
been written up once yeah yeah it was
not fun
embarrassing they're very embarrassing
yeah
especially because it's a very small
unit
so you know there's no like
largeness to hide inside of when you're
feeling that
i don't think i've ever been suspended
definitely been sent home
definitely got fired from one job after
three days of being there oh damn what'd
you do
i protected someone oh good
oh well that's i mean that's that's
heroic
yeah you know i
feel confidently that's good taking the
the cowards lie out
wait no not taking the camera
yeah yeah that was a genuine comment
yeah yeah
anyway that was fun okay chris
parnell yeah not cornell no
cornell
is not with us anymore no longer chris
parnell getting him back it's where you
get an actual character returned
in brooklyn i mean i imagine it
progresses as the show goes on but to
have something like this where he took
someone down and now they're out for
revenge i think it's a really fun plot
and i thought chris parnell was way
funnier here than he was the first time
around yeah but the first time around i
thought like he did his job yeah he did
the that role that he's good at playing
even like elsa now my sketch i remember
him most doing was the the one with will
ferrell angry boss oh no and he's like
i'm cocaine and i'm gonna kill you and
he's got like a spear who tried it one
of the two yeah
um yeah so i i don't uh i don't really
feel like he did anything that's special
the first time around but this one i
thought it was way funnier
and uh yeah that was that was a neat
plot and of course allowing for a moment
of reflection for jake to realize
that
you know
sometimes you got to let people just do
to the trap i found myself asking myself
that question while i was watching this
so if i was in this position and
any job in the end like just because if
someone set me up if i had to be
investigated would i be offended if my
closest colleagues were
you know
to having to
actually put their personal feelings
aside and investigate me truly
i think i would be okay with it i'd be
like you're just doing your job
i get it
uh
at the same time i would be like did i
accidentally do cocaine and i just don't
remember doing okay
that sounds like a thing you would do
and the sound has happened before once
or twice
so
yeah yeah
john you and your white lies take it
away
i've never actually enjoyed a single
episode of this show every review has
been a white lie nice uh no yeah i agree
i thought this was really cool and to
get the surprise factor i feel like we
we've had a couple of characters who
have established themselves as being
recurring but this one was the most sort
of like surprise reveal of all of them
not that it's like the most
uh like wound of a mystery but even
still i thought that was a very kind of
satisfying like oh damn like you know
they lured us in enough to be like
what's going on here is andy is uh jake
you know trying to we know he didn't do
the drugs but for the rest of the stuff
is this just his irresponsibility but no
it turns out not and it's cool because
like
this like that
very specifically but even the little
beat at the end where he's like i think
it's because my dad abandoned me you
know it's like those
those serial elements that help to flesh
out the periphery you know they bother
to put in here that make even you know a
fun you know one-off situation feel like
it's part of the bigger scope of things
i thought was really nice
and uh and yeah i thought the uh
like the back and forth between andy
sandberg and him and the recording of
the tape and everything like they did
get me wondering like damn how are they
gonna find him after all of this and
yeah i mean you know once uh
uh amy and rosa show up you know like
there's a pretty
it happens pretty cleanly and pretty
quickly once it does but i like that you
have that detail like well you know we
found these obnoxious selfies of yours
we found the ice cream truck and that
kind of reminded me of the thing that
happened with scully and hitchcock and
the way that they were able to solve
their case and uh yeah i thought those
kind of bounced off each other in a nice
way and then you have the the the gina c
plot to tie everything else together
and which i found very funny as well
watching uh holt and terry flounder
over how to approach that situation and
i thought that was a good uh sort of
moral debate which is better
uh you know being honest
and dealing with somebody's hurt and
then finding a way to make up for it or
you know
white lying in the moment taking the no
no sarcasm is the coward's lie
but yeah taking that white lie in the
moment and trying to just placate
somebody yeah they had a bunch of nice
character-driven storylines for this
episode
very true yeah
i say lie
by the way i think it's okay to lie
depending on the situation
okay
everybody's got a line everybody's got a
line
yeah like you're 100 honest all the time
never mr john humphrey i have not had
him
a man
man of integrity at all times uh i would
like to be
yeah
i'm trying to do better about that
but i'm way better aligning myself than
others
so
i'm good at making myself think it's
okay
really you know
i think it just depends on the why sure
it always depends on the lie yeah what's
your motivation who's involved how dire
are the circumstances
that's that's what i mean there are some
people i know that have a strict no lie
policy
insanely blunt truth
which i respect
it also depends who you're talking to
i am more honest with people i'm close
to so not john
yeah that makes sense everyone that john
sees me interact with
very honest with that
not john yeah
john i just lie all the time yeah
i was like johnny you're just doing such
a great job you're always on time
you're too fast for me john stop slow
down
[Laughter]
uh
yeah i don't know i guess it's just a
like when i'd say a little lie it's it's
just it's small you know like
like with the stranger i don't really
give a [ __ ] about
well yeah i mean the stakes are low
yeah
but i'm not gonna
i wouldn't lie like i attended your
thing and here's what i thought
that i would be way too kind of paranoid
about getting caught in that
there's somebody else i know there who
could vouch for that is you know
you're looking out of the audience you
could probably see who's there to some
extent you know
yeah sometimes i get back to people
really late
and then i'll say some [ __ ]
sometimes
but really it's pretty honest
usually it's
okay that's different that's a poor
excuse this is what i have there not a
lie
because i go if you can reply
it's like if someone
hits me up on a text message i'll i'll
you know it doesn't take long to just
sit and reply back it doesn't i can
think of like a gazillion text right now
that i have
that i just haven't gone back to yet
because i
don't want
to get into a conversation
because i'm doing a gazillion other
things in real life
so i don't want to get into a
conversation right now and then i
eventually just don't get around to
replying
and then i get back i'm like hey sorry i
remember actually i'm pretty honest
about it i think about it i always say
sorry i'm all over the place right now
and then i usually give them a call if i
care like if i haven't responded to you
in like a week and but if i like you and
i care about you i'll just give you a
call instead and be like look i haven't
plot in a week so i've been so busy i
guess what i've discovered is i i guess
i used to lie about these things i'm
pretty honest about it is that your
margin is it is it usually a week at the
max it depends like if i it just depends
on who it is if i haven't uh some people
i just haven't gone back to and then i i
i honestly just forget i think that's
the thing i don't really leave in is i
just don't say i forget because i'm
afraid to offend them by saying i don't
want you to think i don't care that's
where i leave that out and i like omit
that from the truth yeah i don't i i say
uh
uh i'll i'll be i'll be honest like i've
been so busy just coping things and then
i'm just now catching up on my messages
that's true
a lot of time though it's like oh no i
straight up forgot that you messaged me
yeah i mean that's the snowball for me
typically i don't say i forgot
yeah i think that's the only thing i
don't i'm not honest about it but i feel
like i feel that very much because
that's usually i mean usually for me
it's like a month later i'm responding
to somebody but yeah it's
it's that and it's that thing of i don't
i i wanted to take time to actually
engage and process what you said to me
instead of just like firing back a
you know
a response
just to get it out you know uh so
sometimes i reply to people at like
three four in the morning eight that
does two things
they're not going to reply
yeah
if i'm messaging you that late that's an
indicator yeah i've been doing a lot yes
i'm not like up on late at night just
watching tv it's usually like
trying to get this freaking video done
so um yeah that's uh
you know
she kills two birds in one step you know
you see i message you in the middle of
the night then i'm like yeah
see what i mean
totally trying to communicate stuff
without really
that's that's me a lot of the time too
it's a good three four in the morning
text bag yeah i'm gonna send a bunch of
messages sorry and then i guess the
window because they're not gonna get
back to me for a few hours and then i
don't feel like i gotta get back to you
for a while yeah it's only it's only
guilt out old when somebody responds
within the immediately the five minute
window
but you know there's also cases of like
urgency when like no i need to get back
to this person today i'm really paying
attention to these text messages today
so that's that's why
i make it my business never
to be upset with anybody for
taking a while to text me back
there's people like you and coy and sid
wilder oh good for sure who have like
like their your messages are like
hundreds of notification like there's so
many and i'm just like that is insane
just open some of them and don't reply
because this is just
so i i like yeah i usually have one see
200 messages i'm like oh god please i
have like to anywhere from 25 to 40 on
the average day oh so god that's not too
bad no but i can like bang a lot of them
out
three four in the morning
are you a fast writer in those
situations like can you respond to
somebody pretty quickly and feel like
you engaged or do you like yeah because
i'm honest
the only thing i kind of have to be
careful about is my opener of how i'm
getting back like okay all right
there's only so much people pleasing i
can do
so
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] all my friends a bunch
of [ __ ] losers all you guys yeah
everyone who's in my text messages right
now and i haven't gotten back to you
go to hell yeah
i'm talking about you alex
you andrew thank you
well throw your name in the bible yeah
yeah that's one of the cornerstones of
you and paul's relationship is the
sharing of thumbnails
all right guys well now you've learned a
little bit something about me
so don't text him don't text me
if you want to hear back if i get you
about no i'm going to call these people
later sally i got it back to a lot of
people um
and yeah
it's just
you know because sometimes people get
back to you like right away you're like
just like buy your phone
some people are really fast at
processing those things and i'm not like
brandon i called him i called him
yesterday because i haven't gone back to
him in a while yeah
and
brandon just like no matter what time i
message you
just like
i could go like two weeks without
replying
instant replies you're like damn dude
you're just waiting right by your phone
well and brandon seems like one who is
very adept at living with the phone on
and and near and always kind of it's not
doesn't seem like it's very much tax on
his mental ram
to have you know that ping constantly
going off
yeah so um i gotta i gotta manage that
and then that's my text i got my twitter
messages i got my instagram messages
so they all run together because they're
all text they're just in different
places and after a while i'm just like
look i don't i just don't want to like
type on a screen
i'd like to speak
to you maybe
so yeah but i eventually just give
people calls
it's my way of apologizing that's good
that's good that's a good way to connect
i think it shows you care more it's a
real way to catch up and i can knock out
what you would talk about in text over
like a couple hours in like 10 to 15
minutes
that's the part that i that i struggle
with is especially if i haven't spoken
to somebody in a while i'm like okay now
let's compartmentalize this called a
half an hour most and then i gotta go
you know man that's how you call them
here at the grocery store you're on the
road
you're cleaning you know you let them
know you give them a heads up that's
good i tell i don't tell them they ask
me i feel like yeah i have a strategies
tonight
sometimes that they go on for a long
time like 45 minutes something it
depends on how the conversation is going
yeah or what i'm doing
but yeah you know you usually got to
give a you know set up
a way out
okay like hey i'm on the road i'm gonna
go film soon but i wanted to just catch
up with you hey i'm on my way to go to
the gym while i'm on the road
uh i just wanted to see how you're doing
and i'm sorry for not getting back to
you
you know bam oh i envy that no no it's
called ticking time that weirdly makes
me more tense when i'm like that where
i'm like i only have a limited amount of
time to spend quality time with
their time is valuable yeah and your
time is valuable and you just gotta
be honest if you say that like they have
bad most people have something to do too
and if they don't
should we really be friends sure
[Laughter]
probably i have some friends who don't
really too much and i talk to them all
the time
they're always there for cinemark
[Laughter]
yeah that's why they're at the phone
always ready for your invitation to
another movie yeah it's fun it's fine
yeah man anyway see you guys we'll text
you back
[Music]
you